what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting
to the top 10 most awkward moments from
90 day fiance just a disclaimer
i've never been a big 90 day fiance fan
i haven't
watched a ton of stuff i've just seen
little clips here and there so i don't
know
all the back stories but let me know in
the comments if you guys have a 90 day
fiance
scene that you want me to react to
because i'm trying to do a couple new
things
on this channel okay
because you have to clean the bed the
couples in this series have three months
to tie the knot
or face one of them leaving the country
welcome to ms mojo and today
we'll be counting down our picks for the
top 10 most awkward moments from 90 day
fiance like i'm a student but my parents
are worried about inheritance
because my family without question has
more money than his
before we begin we publish new videos
every day so be sure to subscribe for
more great content
for this list we'll be looking at the
moments on the american documentary
series
and its spin-offs that were painfully
awkward to watch
with the more socially faux pas weird
and uncomfortable the better
you know just try to be like moroccan
people just for one month
i'm not morocco i know but try to
because why do you want me to be
moroccan number 10 meeting the in-laws
i'm excited she exists i'm real so
finally i'm here
it's nice to meet you meeting the
in-laws for the first time is always an
awkward experience but this moment would
take one of the top
prizes kicking off the dinner with a
casual joke
about how they'd warn their son not to
run off fall in love with some girl and
bring her home
whoops russ's parents immediately set
the scene for some uncomfortable tension
the joke was when he first left was you
know don't go down there and fall in
love and
you know bring a girl back home and uh
sure enough he does powell has
discomfort with the whole situation
from her tight smile and unwillingness
to really make a conversation
to russ watching her like a hawk at her
side is very clear
this is one family dinner they probably
wouldn't want to repeat
they're really nice i just want to say
they are really nice but i want my own
space
number nine narkia gets catfished i
don't want to date a guy in this area
because the guys in this area in the
world of cyber love affairs
it pays to be cautious of anyone who
seems too good to be true
especially if they pull the tried and
true nigerian prince tagline
he also told me he was living in alabama
he had a son
and that his son's mother had passed
away
after this couple met in an online group
for plus-sized woman
narkia finds another social media
profile of her fiancees
that he hadn't told her about and it
gets her spidey's senses tingling
she then finds photos of alulo's son
with another woman
that he had told her had passed away at
the end of the day
narkia is left with no choice but to
come to the conclusion
that she's been catfished oops and i'm
just over here stressing not knowing
what's going on
number eight chantal versus the future
mother-in-law
he shares a little too much with his
family and he should keep
our private business private here's
another run-in with the in-laws
the news that chantal's parents wanted
her to sign a prenup with pedro
was awkward enough but his mother's
reaction to the news was even more
[Music]
cringe-worthy
speaking lightning fast spanish and
going off about the stupid americans
with chantelle right there listening
pedro's mother makes her feelings about
the situation with chantelle's parents
well-known
with little regard for her future
daughter-in-law's feelings watching
chantal sit quietly and listen
when it was obvious she was upset was
difficult especially as she never
actually comes back with a reply until
the facetime call is over
i don't need that in my life and if i'm
going to be calling her my mother-in-law
she's gonna have to calm down
number seven
why is the mom getting mad about the
prenup did she want a free meal
do you really love him seriously
you're gonna tell me that this isn't a
big problem
um red flag anybody when questioned
about her feelings for her fiance matt
alla is brutally honest in saying she's
not really sure if she loves him yet
but is still completely okay with
marrying him then you don't love him
i don't know
but you're getting married anyway
obviously blown away well in other
countries that's like more common and
one of the more rational people in the
room
matt's friend tries to coax some
reasoning out of the ukrainian
bride-to-be
to no avail with matt himself and
another female friend sitting in silence
this awkward interrogation made for a
pretty significant hiccup
in the future of matt and allah's
relationship i've got to know that
you're here for him
in order for me to what else can she
possibly say she said this
five times already but you're you're
getting hoodwinked
number six nicki's airport she just
wants that
to rival this is the happiest day of my
life i mean i'm crying but it's the
happiest day of my life
with an age difference that was already
making audiences cringe
19 versus 58 the way mark behaved once
he picked
nikki up from the airport was weird from
the start when she placed her hand on
the window of his car
and apparently left fingerprints mark
wasted no time in telling her it wasn't
allowed
that's not allowed no that was one of
the rules when my children were
really they never touched never touch
the window because it's so i'm not
allowed to touch the window you don't
touch the window
to make matters even creepy fear he
tells her that it was one of the rules
when his children were young
that they couldn't touch the windows
reprimanding her from messing with his
happiness
the last time we checked he was her
fiance not her
father you're weird i know you're always
weird i'm always weird
number five george's money confession so
you're basically saying that you're just
dating me because i can buy you things
yes what's worse marrying someone only
for money or
telling someone you're a millionaire to
get them to marry you
either way when the truth finally
surfaced in this ugly situation
it wasn't received well a couple that
had their issues long before they said i
do
george finally dropped the news on his
wife that not only was he not a
millionaire
but he also was in debt needless to say
oh my gosh notoriously hot
tempered anfisa wasn't happy i do bring
your fiancee from
abroad and getting married when you're
in debt when you don't have your
together dragging him over the coals for
lying to her about being able to fund
her expensive tastes
this was a situation that dropped jaws
the moment it aired
business doesn't go well what do you
want me to do this never when well you
just lied to me whenever
you were lying how do you know don't
interrupt me number four
aziz and mike's bedroom roadblock but 90
days is flying by
and our sex life is still at a
standstill this was the elephant in the
room
with this conversation happening over
the folding of laundry
and aziza doing everything she could to
avoid eye contact
had audiences cringing in their seats i
think we need to wait
with sex
we were supposed to do as soon as you
got here yeah
after saying she wanted to wait a little
longer before she and mike consummated
their relationship
aziz as reluctance to pursue the subject
and mike's persistence put
everyone on edge then there was a creepy
half smile he kept on his face the whole
time
as well as his enthusiasm about one day
having kids
perhaps mike needs to be reminded of the
virtue of patience
aziza may be a little more uptight than
some american woman
i think that you know she's just still
worried about our sexual relationship
i hope she becomes a lot more
comfortable number three azan tells
nicole to work out
you're gonna miss the dessert um
no azan made his feelings about nicole's
body known from the day she landed
however the way he went about trying to
persuade her to get in a bit better
shape
was not exactly the greatest idea as she
struggled up a sand dune in the middle
of the desert
he urged her on by telling her how lazy
she was and how she needed to work out
more
okay
he followed this up by telling the
cameras that he didn't think she was
healthy
which isn't something your partner
should be telling you at least not so
bluntly
encouraging your fiance to pursue health
is one thing but straight up telling
them they're lazy is beyond rude
number two muhammad doesn't hold back i
was
expecting like way much better than
i find out when i came here this was one
couple that had a pretty significant
history of issues
in the season one finale of the spin-off
90-day fiance happily ever after
muhammad and danielle were questioned on
their troubles between the sheets
during the couple's tell-all segment
screaming in front of her teenagers
i want my sex tonight if you don't give
me my sex tonight
i will i will i will call the
immigration i will get you deported
the interview went from casual to cringy
in a heartbeat
with muhammad opening up about the
issues danielle had
and some
[Music]
of her wilder past behavior between name
calling
accusation and the stunned looks on the
faces of all the other couples present
this interview was shocking in more ways
than one thank you very much for
if you're asking me like why i'm not
having sex with her then you put it
out there i have to explain it you know
all right before we reveal our top pick
here are a few honorable mentions
[Music]
got mad at me because i left her and i
tried to go see the lawyer alone
that was nice of you that shows how
really you are
you walked away from me i'm here trying
to talk to you
you know it's just because i'm better
than you i don't do it back to you guys
you are you
mohammed you used me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number one the awkward silence
did you regret etching the word idiot
into the car why not
do the emmys have a category for most
awkward moment
during yet another revealing tell-all
episode the infamous anfisa
was questioned about some of her wilder
antics when asked if she felt any
remorse for keying the word idiot into
the side of george's car
on fiza proceeded to kick-start the
longest awkward that's like
the definition of pretty book a pause in
the history of recorded tv
complete with everything but the
crickets in the background the studio
went silent for what felt like i didn't
stay together
like hours before she finally attempted
to defend herself
storming out shortly afterwards
audiences could practically
feel the awkward
do you agree with our picks check out
these other great
that was actually pretty entertaining
that was my first like
true 90 day fiance experience i enjoyed
it a lot
let me know in the comments if you like
this type of reaction because if you
guys do
i am going to keep doing them do not
forget to subscribe to the channel as
you guys know
trying to hit 20 000 subscribers and i'm
getting closer to that every day but
each and every one of you help
and do not forget to ring the
notification bell as well
i'll talk to you guys next time